imagine you have a looker dashboard
filled with useful data and insights
many of your users will find the
dashboard helpful and use it often
but your users spend most of their time
on existing applications and workflows
how can your dashboard reach your users
in their current context
well
embed the dashboard into your existing
applications so your user can act on
data insights without leaving their app
or disrupting their workflows
hi
welcome to our video series on embedding
looker i'm jeremy a developer relations
engineer at looker
in this video we will explore the
multiple ways you can embed your local
content via iframes
[Music]
there are three options for embedding
via iframe
private embedding
sso single sign-on embedding and sso
embedding with the embed sdk
let's do a quick overview of each iframe
embedding option and how your host
application can interact and communicate
with your iframe by the way a quick
knowledge check
for the rest of this video we assume you
have a basic knowledge of javascript and
the iframe html element
first
let's introduce you to the private
embedding option
let's look at your host applications dom
you create an iframe inside the dom
then you take a modified url of your
looker content and set it on your iframe
source attribute
and now you have embedded liquor content
in your iframe
keep in mind for this option your user
must log into looker via your admin's
chosen authentication mechanism
the user's looker account must have the
right permissions to access the embedded
content so
consider private embedding if you need a
quick and easy embedding option and your
user can log into your liquor instance
but what if you want your host
application to control user
authentication and
authorization for example your user
authenticates with an identity provider
connected to your host application
all separate from your looker instance
then try out our ssl embedding option
again you create an iframe in your host
application
but this time
you point the iframe source attribute to
a unique
one-time use url that you must generate
for each embed user session this
one-time use url sets the content access
permissions of the session
the url logs in your user as an existing
looker embed user or creates a new one
with the content access permissions
consider the sso embedding option if
your host application controls user
authentication and authorization
next
let's look at the sso embedding with the
embed sdk option
this is our recommended embedding option
it's the same as the previously
mentioned sso embedding option however
your host application does not directly
manage the iframe
instead your host application calls the
javascript embed sdk to create and
manage the iframe
just like i described for the previous
sso embedding option you must still
generate a unique url for every embed
user session
but the embed sdk with our accompanying
code samples partly automates the url
generation and manages the iframe for
you we recommend this option the most
because of the embed sdk's convenient
javascript api and ease of use lastly
let's look at how your host application
can communicate with your iframe to make
your embedded content more interactive
your iframe and host application can
communicate with each other with all the
previous embedding options
your iframe emits an event when its
state changes for example when a
dashboard finishes loading
your host application can listen to
these events
and react accordingly
also your host application can send
messages to the iframe to change the
iframe state like telling the iframe to
load a new dashboard
if you use the embed sdk
then your host application calls the
sdk's javascript api to listen to events
and send messages to the iframe
but if you do not use the embed sdk
then your host application will use the
window interface to listen to events
and send messages to the iframe
in conclusion you can embed liquid
content in an iframe in multiple ways
depending on your needs
and your host application can interact
with the iframe
if you don't know where to start
we recommend getting started with
private embedding because it is our
simplest embedding option
and then we recommend you get started
with the sso embedding with the embed
sdk to help you get more familiar with
embedding looker and with that
you will soon be an expert in embedding
looker so check out our developer portal
linked in the description below and get
started embedding your liquor content
also stay tuned for future videos in
this series where we'll walk you through
how to embed looker in more detail
see you next time
[Music]
you